por tercer día consecutivo israel
mantiene cerrados todos los pasos a
gaza' desde carreteras fronterizas hasta
líneas de tren y el cruce de erez la
medida se debe a posibles represalias
que podría tomar la jihad islámica
palestina por el arresto en cisjordania
de uno de sus líderes más anp saadi
ocurrido el lunes durante una redada
israelí en yenín desde la serie de
ataques a finales de marzo el campo de
refugiados de yenín se ha convertido en
un foco de las operaciones de las
fuerzas israelíes y en este último
durante la captura de saadi los
enfrentamientos también causaron la
muerte de un joven de 17 años en este
contexto la jihad islámica ha elevado su
estado de alerta y preparación mientras
israel que considera el grupo
organización terrorista lo tomó como
amenaza directa con posibles ataques a
civiles y lanzamientos de misiles
antitanque este jueves tanto medios
israelíes como palestinos han reportado
que israel ha desplegado drones armados
sobre la franja algo que se suma al
llamado de 100 reservistas como refuerzo
mediadores de egipto y qatar están ya
intentando evitar una nueva escalada y
atraves de ellos la yihad islámica
presentó tres demandas que la familia de
saadi pueda visitarlo y verificar su
salud que cesen las incursiones
israelíes en cisjordania ocupada y por
último que se libere a jalil aguad a un
palestino en huelga de hambre que está
en huelga de hambre como protesta por su
detención sin cargos ni juicio del lado
israelí el bloqueo ha dejado aisladas a
dos comunidades del lado palestino más
de 14.000 gazatíes con permiso de
trabajo en israel han quedado encerrados
y la falta de combustible agudizaría los
apagones eléctricos que están durando
más de 10 horas sin contar la parálisis
que esto supone para la entrada de ayuda
humanitaria